welcome back to Hannity here now with
reaction to our opening monologue all
this breaking news out of Washington the
author of the best-selling book
vengeance former Speaker of the House
Fox News contributor Newt Gingrich the
most amazing thing here is this is
supposed to be a special counsel on
Trump Russia collusion the big
indictment today well denounced the leak
Friday but denounced today Paul Manafort
mr. speaker 31 pages no Trump Russia
collusion zero but all these other
issues I am talking about the fusion GPS
dossier the uranium one deal we have a
boatload of evidence what's your take
well first of all the United States
Congress should open an investigation to
protect the rights of Americans you have
an out of control prosecutor who was
supposed to be looking into Russian
collusion who think about this Paul
Manafort voluntarily showed up today
walked in turned himself over is not a
threat to the public was not a threat to
flee yet this summer the Justice
Department broke into his house at five
o'clock in the morning got his blade he
and his wife and their pajamas yeah you
know I mean you have to say to yourself
this is the most grotesque abuse and
then you look at as you pointed out
earlier a twenty nine-year-old who is
now complete guilty to what - having
said the wrong thing to the FBI having
facts even wrong he clearly lied would
you like to go back and look at the
Clinton staff John Podesta notice that
even the susan collins tonight senator
collins said he's going to have to come
back and testify implying i think they
did not tell the truth you go back and
look at all the people who've been lying
and we finally get down to a twenty
nine-year-old guy
not that he that they convicted him of
doing anything wrong in the meeting with
the russians but he gave the FBI the
wrong date now i think this thing is
going to grow into a bigger and bigger
and bigger scandal and at the center of
it
is a corrupt Justice Department whose
professional staff was totally in the
tank for Hillary Clinton and
has been grotesquely abusing its power
you know here's the thing that I can't
get can you think of any reason on God's
green earth that Barack Obama Hillary
putting aside all the evidence that we
now know they had that Vladimir Putin
had agents in America bribing extorting
money laundering racketeering they knew
in 2009 Holder knew it
Muller had to know it Rosenstein knew it
the two guys in particular in this case
why would Hillary or Obama just on the
surface of it why would you ever give a
hostile regime and a bad actor Vladimir
Putin in Russia 20% of our uranium and
that's what he set out for and we knew
he set out and he was committing crimes
to get there how is that possible
well well first of all if the numbers
are right and I I think this is another
thing Congress should insist on and Don
bringing in the information and
compelling it to be delivered the
numbers are right there were various
sources associated with this who gave a
hundred and forty five million dollars
to the Clinton Foundation through a
Canadian Foundation which could avoid
the agreement they made with Obama about
reporting their donations in the United
States now as bare as bad as the Bill
Clinton $500,000 speech was for a
Russian bank this is 290 times as much
money so you have to say to yourself oh
gosh why would Bill and Hillary go
through with the deal that might involve
one hundred and forty five million
dollars well I'm gonna be old-fashioned
here Sean I know it's a shot follow the
money they wanted the money this is
about corruption Hillary from from the
time she made money illegally on cattle
futures for her entire career has
thought she could get away with this
stuff it's only as it begins to unravel
now that we begin to rise it this is
truly horrifying you have two attorneys
general united states you have the
director of the FBI mr. Mulder you have
a local attorney who becomes the deputy
who then bring the Attorney General who
then brings in Muller you have a level
of corruption that's on a match
and let me say quoting Allen Wells Oh at
Gettysburg College as a student of this
he believes this is the most corrupt
presidency in American history we've
only touched the beginning of about the
ultimate spring folding but you never
got to my film administration is the
most corrupt but is there any reason you
can think of that you'd ever give 20% of
the foundational material American
assets to Putin and Russia what would
what did America get what Obama you can
they didn't well I'm gonna the Clinton's
got a hundred and forty five million
dollars they didn't care remember Obama
is the president who said to the acting
Russian for the then Russian President
Medvedev let us get was caught on camera
let us get through the election and then
we can be a lot more generous to you I
mean why would you think that these guys
who are Looney tune liberals who have no
idea of the real world would have
worried about giving Obama of a giving
Putin uranium there they were out of
touch with reality they're still out of
touch with reality I got asked this it's
a fact I got to ask you about the fusion
GPS story I gotta ask you about how
corrupt the media is and also you won't
believe what Hillary Clinton said about
our coverage about this show of her
scandals new